That's life.
Haha.
Mum?
Something.
It was my bike.
Came off, Mum.
So hungry, I forgot.
Get going.
Come on.
Brubble, taste some bicycle grease.
Tastes yucky, yeah.
With a decent infection, we could move inside and eat properly.
This kid forgets to wash his hands.
Soap makes me feel so sick.
The mouth.
First stage in the process of digestion.
The teeth are specialized tools.
The incisors cut, the canines shred, and the molars grind.
helps to mash the food and the salivary glands provide digestive juices which also disinfect the
mouth and help to keep it free of bacteria the mouth produces two liters of saliva per day i'm
hungry don't you tastes good on the tongue the tongue is sensitive to four basic elements of
taste bitter acidic sweet and salty it's not enough let's run a test ready for the taste test
it's ready for your taste test sir very short on salt i'd say my friend very short indeed
Just a minute.
Thanks.
Tell them it's not enough salt.
Hey, you there! Listen!
Who?
Yes, I'm talking to you.
We need more salt, so don't just send their gawping.
Get this message off.
Yes, if you tell me how and to whom.
Look, son, this is a nerve cell, isn't it?
So why don't you send an impulse up to the brain?
What's an impulse?
You'll see.
Eeehaha! Goodbye! Salt. Right! It could do with a bit more. Ready for the taste test? It's ready for your taste test now, sir. Far too salty, too salty. Right! Excuse me, sir. Please, can you explain why we always work with salt and only salt? Well, we specialize in salt. We're the great experts on the subject, you see. There are other highly qualified specialists who deal in the other tastes. For example, there's the sugar expert. Mmm. There's the bitterness specialist. Here's the head of the acidity department.
So, enjoying a friendly chat are we?
Go on then, what are you waiting for?
The taste is too salty, send the message.
Wicked!
Mine's about sugar and it's just as important as your signal.
I'm carrying a message about a bitter taste
and I have to deliver it upstairs as soon as possible.
Hard cheese, my signal concerns acidity and that could be dangerous.
You'll just have to let me get on ahead.
We've only matched in speed, all four of us.
Yes, so we're bound to arrive at the same time.
Of course, we must arrive together so that the brain can combine
The brain can combine all the four main tastes.
Together, then there's no point in racing.
Precisely.
Quite right.
Too true.
What's that, for heaven's sake?
It's pepper, maestro.
It is eating.
Yes, it's pepper, all right.
Far too much pepper, in fact.
I transmit that.
No, before we can transmit, we need all four basic taste elements in combination.
Can smell it, but there's not a sign of any taste message yet.
Wonder what's keeping the speedies.
The emicidity.
Please, goodbye and transmit.
Listen here, you boys. I want to see an improvement in your attitude next time.
Taste is no laughing matter.
It's a symphony of sensations like an orchestra playing.
And I want you all in tune right from the start next time. Got that?
It was nice.
Did you enjoy it, Peter?
I like it salty.
Hey, get down, Roly-Poly. Don't beg.
Mum says it's bad for you if you put too much salt on your food.
It's very good for you. It makes your teeth nice and strong.
Your teeth are so pretty, Mummy. They're all shiny and white like ivory.
They are ivory.
Like an elephant?
That's right. But our ivory is covered in enamel, and enamel is very hard.
Enamel? You mean like they use on saucepans?
It's disgusting.
You know, it's been ages since we've had a real treat like sugar. Sugar.
Oh, shut up. You're only depressing me.
We may as well admit it, chaps. Sugar is the only thing that makes our miserable life worth living.
Sugar's what we want! Sugar's what we need! Sugar, please!
Sweet, alright. Send a message, there's far too much sugar.
Some sugar!
You skinny little weaklings, now something that'll put hair on your chest.
Sugar!
*Loud laughter*
Sit, men!
We're ready to go into action!
Just look at this unconquered molar!
Gleaming white!
Shall we tackle it?
What do you say?
Men, you're going to tackle the east face
after we've had some sugar!
That's where we'll begin!
Start here!
this position is far too exposed we couldn't defend ourselves here over there we can shelter
safely in the crevices until we're well and truly dug in so cut the cackle and have more sugar men
toes in the spot men so let's get busy yes chief we've been bashing away this enamel for hours but
we haven't made the slightest impression because tooth enamel is the hardest material in the human
body i never told you men that it would be easy digging this cavity it takes patience and work
I'm bored with this work. Why don't we do something else?
Shall I spell it out for you in words of one syllable, you blithering idiot?
You've only got one talent, and that's for making holes in teeth.
So get on with it.
Until we've made the cavity and got inside the tooth.
Then we'll be living on easy street.
We can multiply and hand out some punishment to this body.
Really? Can we hurt it?
Yes, toothache.
Then when we get as far as the root, we can move into the bloodstream.
That's what I like best.
We take over the whole organism.
From Beaton, bring the drill!
Professional.
He is a professional.
That fellow's got a brilliant record.
He's worked on three enormous cavities and an infected root.
I've always dreamt of finding a big black cavity for myself, where I can live happily ever after.
This is a tough one.
The anomaly's young and hard as nails, but leave it to me.
I'll break through in the end.
Kid's got to.
Over here, Mom.
Jump, Roly-Poly.
We're teaching Roly-Poly to jump.
Sit, Roly-Poly.
Now, pay attention. Have you brushed your teeth?
Come on, Roly-Poly. Big jump.
No, I forgot, Mum, but I promise I'll do them tonight.
Peter, you'll brush your teeth this minute, do you hear?
You should always brush your teeth after eating something sweet.
Otherwise, you'll end up with rotten teeth.
Do rotten teeth hurt, Mummy?
Very much. Come on, hurry up.
It's a toothbrush. For himself!
We can't temporary setback.
I don't want you fellows to lose heart.
Remember that everything comes to him who waits.
I reckon.
What's that?
We've actually had good luck.
You must be joking.
No, we're very lucky to be alive.
That toothpaste could have wiped out the lot of us.
If I don't get sugar soon, I'll go out of my mind.
Our luck has turned.
It's sugar!
Feel the strength seeping out of me.
Got enough sugar to start multiplying.
Get to work.
As I tell you, we're nearly at the root of pie.
Slowing down, boss.
Running out of sugar for the men.
Take a short break, then.
She'll be eating any moment now, and she can't be bothered to brush her teeth afterwards.
You can tell the men there's no need to worry.
It's on time. It's raining, sugar!
Wide, little one.
It's got quite a deep cavity, and I'd better see to it right away before it gets any closer to the root.
Day, don't I, Mummy? Sometimes I even brush them today.
My dear little girl, you ought to brush your teeth each and every time you eat anything with sugar in it.
Doctor?
There are colonies of bacteria living in your mouth, and their only source of nourishment is sugar.
They transform the sugar into acid, which then attacks your teeth.
But that simply can't happen if you brush away the sugar.
It's hurting because the nerve is affected, and it has begun to send pain messages.
And if those germs get into the bloodstream, they can spread their infection anywhere in the body.
Luckily for you, the body's police force never sleeps.
This, huh? This is a blood vessel. It's full of blood.
So what's blood for?
It brings oxygen to this tooth, then it goes off into the body.
What that means, if we get into this blood vessel, the whole body's our oyster.
You'd have to be very careful. Bloodstream is patrolled by policemen.
You're just a scaredy cat. Come on, guys.
Come on, come on, guys.
So far, so good. No sign of trouble today.
I wouldn't take anything for granted, Constable.
A tooth is a very sensitive area, and it's an ideal infiltration route.
Calling lymphocyte patrol. This is Lieutenant Jumbo in tooth number 17.
A highly suspicious group has headed your way. Intercept them, please.
Lead them to us, Lieutenant. We'll investigate.
I've never seen blue corpuscles before.
Streptococcus mutinus.
Let's get rid of them. Ready?
Right.
...to clean up the cavity now. Quite painless.
Remember, child, that teeth have to last a lifetime.
Keep sugar away from them and you'll starve those bacteria with nothing better to do than dig holes.